trouver le bon mouvement le bon dosage
régulièrement la golfeuse
professionnelle manon gide ali 27 ans
répète ses gammes sur les parcours
yvelinois et notamment sur celui du golf
de la boulie à versailles un cocon
qu'elle a rejoint à l'âge de 14 ans ç'a
toujours été un grand club
depuis tout le moins je suis arrivé ici
à l'âge de 14 ans et c'est vrai que le
racing c'était le club sportif avec les
tous les bons espoirs
et donc c'était j'étais vraiment ravi
d'être accueillis ici et j'étais surtout
très fier de pouvoir représenter le club
en golfeur de pouvoir me battre pour les
couleurs bleu ciel et blanc sur
l'apprentissage du haut niveau est
également passé par les états unis à 18
ans la golfeuse parfaire ses études dans
l'université d'arizona pendant quatre
années un vrai plus selon cette fan de
tiger woods quand je suis arrivé là bas
c'était vraiment une autre dimension
c'est à dire que là bas les
infrastructures tout est mis en place
pour le sportif pour qu'ils se sentent
bien pour qui perce
j'ai appris beaucoup de choses surtout
notamment par rapport à l'aspect un peu
mentale l'aspect stratégique très
positif là bas ils sont vraiment c'était
une belle expérience de vie une
expérience bénéfique en 2016 m'allonger
dali passe professionnel elle est
aujourd'hui la quatrième française sur
le ladies european tour après une année
2009 1 réussit là j'ai eu deux années
qui ont été plutôt satisfaisante la
cette année je fini 33e européenne au
ranking
ça a été ma meilleure année depuis mon
passage prolongé dali veut continuer sa
progression pour accomplir ses rêves
participer un jour à une semaine cup une
compétition qui oppose l'europe aux
états unis maman j'ai des lièvres
également faire partie de l'aventuré des
jeux olympiques de 2024
il va falloir gagner des tournois il va
faire performer parce que il faut
marquer pas mal de point au niveau
ranking mondial et le ranking mondial
malheureusement quand on est en europe
c'est dur de marquer des points par
rapport au tournoi qui aux états unis
donc va falloir faire en europe
avant de penser aux jeux olympiques
m'allonger delhi espère réussir sa
rentrée sur le circuit européen en 2021
objectif de sa saison remporter une
victoire et intégrer le top 15 en fin
d'année